nein hast du alles für die user kekse
die hatten nur noch datteln bier und
erdnussbutter dass er super ich habe
auch weiße riesen boden also das bier
ist für dich oder ja ja klar
froh ist dann ja was machen wir denn
eigentlich für rosa kekse ja das ist
einfach so ein paar häschen backen
nehmen da erdnussbutter datteln und
boden stampft man jetzt schon mal wirft
man erst an erst anwerfen und dann
stampfen
ist ja nicht so dass ich hier wohne
genau so fühlt man sich nach einem
gespräch mit markus söder also hellbraun
und matschig vor allem matschig also
mein hase sieht deutlich besser aus als
daher meine das ist einfach nur anders
trotzdem ist etwas besonderes und wird
von der gesellschaft akzeptiert
das ist ein alternativer haben genau
gemerkt wieder mal politik ist ein derby
business wegen hier ja schön sie zu
sehen her coole wie verbringen sie denn
die ostertage in der wohnung hier zu
hause viel kann man da nicht machen ein
bisschen spazieren gehen vielleicht aber
viel mehr ist ja nicht drin
sieht man sich als fdp ja eigentlich
auch im home office wie ein streber an
manche jahr es gibt kollegen die haben
zu hause auch eine krawatte an und
andere versuchen das auszugleichen durch
besonders innige schwere kleidung wie
verbringen sie denn ostern weil in der
fdp muss man ja gar nicht lange suchen
findet man zu rodeln kubicki hose ja
absolut und zwar hunderte sind da sind
da versteckt nämlich an sollten pfleger
und pflegerinnen in deutschland
eigentlich eine gehaltserhöhung kriegen
oder sagen sie einmal am tag klatschen
reicht
ich finde es gut dass jetzt die
betroffenen verbände sich darauf
geeinigt haben dass eine sonderzahlung
kommen soll 1500 euro soll jeder
bekommen
und das ganze soll steuerfrei sein finde
ich gut sie kann jetzt nicht mehr
rausgehen sich nicht mehr mit freunden
treffe ist das überhaupt schlimmer als
junger liberaler
doch die zwei tier das man kann sich mit
einem freund oder einer freundin das
brauche jetzt ein kompletter spd ist
weil in der steppe habe ich keine also
sie helfen da wo die not am größten ist
wobei die jetzt wieder auftrieb sind
durch aktives verstecken oder
parteivorsitzenden und verwendung von
olaf scholz ist die spd jetzt wieder im
aufwind das ist ostern in der spd da
werden die parteivorsitzenden versteckt
gekreuzigt und ostern in der csu ist
wenn die parteivorsitzenden sich bemalen
oder wenn markus söder an die wand
genagelt wird aber als fdp versteckt man
traditionell nur eier von fabergé oder
klar
mit goldrand auf jeden fall sollte
dinger solche dinger jetzt sind wir
wieder bei kubicki oder
absolut wir sprechen gleich noch mit
philipp amthor haben sie eine frage für
den kreisverband oder das ganz wichtig
dass immer auch mitschüler panther
gesprochen wird ja philipp am tor in
einem gespräch ist sowie corona in einem
gespräch also es braucht einfach damit
relevant ist was muss muss es gehen ja
das wird sonst auch nicht geklickt
einfach man muss es ganz klar zu sagen
glauben sie dass die politik unter
anderem deshalb so fix reagiert weil
sehr viele politiker zur risikogruppe
gehören
ich glaube das hat damit nichts zu tun
aber es stimmt viele politiker sind
tatsächlich gefährdet und man sollte man
bedenken die durchseuchung scheint die
fdp tatsächlich am größten wir sind die
vorderste front der korona durchsetzung
im deutschen bundestag
also sie neben einem system in dem sie
für die herdenimmunität sorgen ja ja
dass die fdp doch mal zu etwas nutze
ja ich glaube wir haben keine ernst
gemeinten fragen mehr
ich habe nie ernst gemeinte fragen an
fdp politiker
wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich nie wieder
aber im echten leben rennen politik ja
politiker immer weg von uns gerne nie
weg aber es wird nie gesendet
tja woran das wohl liegen mag dann
arbeiten sie noch ein bisschen an ihrer
relevanz und das beste war schon als der
coole gesagt hat dass kubicki solche
dinge art oder frage ich mich auch
manchmal wie werden diese leute
vorbereitet von dem partei weil wir die
einfach mal bemalen ja wir müssen
erraten was ja normal
ok mainz ist er ein bisschen abstrakt da
ganz scheinbar auch eine fröhliche
person die vorne eine beule am kopf hat
ja das ist das letzte was der person
geblieben ist friedrich meer abgehalten
das ist eine abkürzung für das
alternative
es ist wichtig dass es zwei sind was ist
es 22 altmaier
peter altmaier respekt dachten wir
eigentlich jedes mal wenn du einen
schlechten witz macht trinken
und das ist jetzt schon besorgt dass er
nicht im krankenhaus
sieht einfach aus wie ein gelb ich weiß
gar nicht ob der alkohol drin ist kost
prost auf postern
ja wie geht es ihnen in dieser zeit ja
sehr gut geht es mir ich hoffe ihr habt
eure paartherapie auch gut überstanden
ja man sieht wir sind immer noch dazu
verdonnert mit leuten zu sprechen
gemeinsam sie sind ja die große hoffnung
der cdu
wie fühlt es sich an die hoffnung eine
hoffnungslosigkeit zu sein
ich sehe bei der cdu keine
hoffnungslosigkeit sondern ich sehe dass
die probleme löst so wie es im moment in
die leute auch gut und deswegen haben
wir auch eine große zukunft wir froh
sind sie denn dass nur alte leute zur
risikogruppe zählen und nicht geistig
alte also erstmal um jetzt dieses ganze
album thema zunehmend geistig natürlich
mich übrigens gar nicht so ein geistig
ziemlich fit und ansonsten was dieses
thema jugend und ältere angeht da muss
ich schon sagen das habe ich mal gelesen
es irgendwie ganz passend zu sagen ja
ich bin zu jung um mich für corona zu
interessieren es ungefähr so als wenn
man zu sagen würde ich bin zu alt als
dass ich mich um klimawandel sorgen also
geht uns schon alle denken sie sich in
diesen zeiten auch manchmal alkohol adu
alter zerstörer und da habt ihr aber
lange gebraucht um dienste skript oder
aber naja wir versuchen hier immer die
waage zu halten zwischen sachthemen und
schabernack bei der heute show ja das
ist auch gut aber ein bisschen
schabernack gehört den hals das könnt
ihr mir ja auch was haben sie denn
gehamstert ja also im jedenfalls kein
toilettenpapier da habe ich mich darüber
gewundert wie das große toilettenpapier
haben es dann jetzt ausgebrochen ist da
gibt es in diesen spannenden statistiken
dass die franzosen irgendwie rotwein
hamstern und virtuellen papier sagt ja
auch manches aus also den großen run als
toilettenpapier der ist nicht so richtig
nachvollziehen und erhält seit wochen an
also das war bei mir jetzt nicht so der
fall und sonst so ein bisschen
vorratshaltung bayer glaube ich noch nie
ganz verkehrt aber alles mit ein
bisschen masters funktioniert dann schon
also sie hängen euch die ganze zeit am
bildschirm könnte man sagen sie holen
ihre jugend nach kein grund zur sorge
ich es trotzdem auch noch bücher ja und
auch
es ist alles gut und ansonsten würde ich
sagen ist in der tat jetzt mehr am
schreibtisch mehr irgendwie mit video
calls mehr mit telefonkonferenzen und
das hat alles vor und nachteile würde
ich mir sein wie verbringen sie denn die
ostertage
naja die ostertage natürlich auch ein
bisschen social distanzen überschattet
aber mit der familie verbringen ich sie
trotzdem zu hause bei mir in mecklenburg
vorpommern das ist auch ganz gut und
dann wenn man es im reduzierten mars
jetzt ohne große familienfeier machen
aber trotzdem ist glaube ich familiäres
beisammensein gehört ja auch dazu
ich glaube auf unser gepäck ist jetzt
fertig vielen lieben dank herr am tor
habt ihr denn gebacken kann ich mir dann
auch tipps abholen das gehört hier nicht
so zu meinen stärken was gibt es den
keks ja wir haben einfach nur wir haben
eigentlich einfach nur das zusammen
geschmissen was wir gefunden haben
das waren datteln und erdnussbutter und
weiße bohnen
aber wir haben es natürlich klassisch
cdu mäßig gemacht also sie hat schon
gebacken ich habe daneben gestanden und
hat gute tipps gegeben
naja ich war so sauer mal mit guten
tipps ist gelingt mir -button manchmal
nicht so da ist man dann auch mal selbst
gefordert aber immerhin ich bin gespannt
was bei euch raus kommt wünscht guten
genuss dann wird euch schöne ostern und
ich freue mich dass wir uns dann im
reallife auch irgendwann mal wieder
gehen ich glaube die kekse sind fertig
war super das nicht nach ostern aussieht
dann weiß ich auch nicht
das fest der auferstehung auf ein blech
also dass philipp am turm mit uns
gesprochen hat ist für mich das größere
osterwunder ja das ist eine kontroverse
meinung aber gib mir noch drei gläser
eierlikör und ich stimme dir zu
das kriegen wir hin wie wäre es denn
wenn wir den häschen mundschutz anziehen
das ist eine gute idee dann sind sie
geschützt vielleicht kriegen wir dann
eine kochsendung das wäre super aber ich
mach nur einer kochsendung mit dir wenn
immer noch politiker zwischengeschaltet
werden
köster lichter hazell qh ich finde das
sehr lecker mit eierlikör schmeckt es
noch besser christa dual zerstören
bleibt zu hause leute vor ostern wo wir
bessere zeit post
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
los los du scheiße fährt haye